all i have for you is a word tell it
i've been working with the imax format
for years now and
it has this extraordinary strength and
power in terms of
how deeply it can take the audience into
the story now imhack's camera will make
you commit it keeps you engaged keeps
everybody locked in
and i love that this is my third film
with chris
nolan every production has more and more
sequences in it
that we chose to shoot on imax we used
more cameras and shot more film
than i think any project's ever shot
hoyter and his team were able to get the
camera absolutely
everywhere that i could conceive of we
had such fun with them we were just
using them as if they were any old
camera
they're like kids they're like we're
just oh well actually we can set up here
we can
they just they get excited about what
they can create what we can find
i think we did a lot of things that you
haven't really seen
done before we wanted to not only shoot
imex
we wanted the imax cameras to run
backwards time travel
no inversion
whoa chris is really great in that he
wants it for real he wants it in camera
he doesn't want to do cg i think the
audience is always
aware on some level of the difference
between things that are animated
and something that's been photographed
i'm hoping to give them a reason for
reapproaching action cinema
people always talk about imex oh it's
big for me it's also something else
it's something very visceral to really
feel it
on a gut sense you need that large
format
you want to crash a plane you're not
from the air that was so dramatic
it's a really extraordinary format and
where people are able to experience the
film that way they're going to get the
highest
possible sense of immersion into the
world of tenant
well how big a plane that part is a
little dramatic
you